Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and now that
we know Thor 3 will be the tipping point of
the movie universe in phase 3 I wanted to
explain a little about what that story is
from the comics, and how it’s going to connect
with the other films.
There are a few details like main cast and
timeline things that have been confirmed.
So let’s start with what we know.
Also hello any new people, if you’re just
finding me for the first time.
I’m do weekly marvel videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
The events of Thor will pick up directly after
the final moments of Avengers 2.
Even though Captain America 3 will be the
next movie released.
So the plot of both those movies will be happening
at the same time.
It makes sense, Civil War tears earth apart
while Ragnarok tears
the 9 realms apart.
Tom Hiddleston will be back, he’d have to
be.
Loki was masquerading as Odin at the end of
Dark World.
Idris Elba even spoiled one of the post credits
scenes for Avengers 2 by saying he and Tom
Hiddleston were in
the movie.
For those asking, there will be multiple end
credit scenes during Avengers 2.
They’ll all be things that help lay the
groundwork for the craziness that is phase
3.
That’s where the subtitle Ragnarok comes
in.
In a way it defines what Phase 3 is going
to be all about.
Complete chaos in the Marvel Universe with
the promise that everyone will rise again
stronger than ever.
In norse mythology, Ragnarok is an end of
days epic battle and natural disasters involving
Odin and the other gods.
At the end of which the world is submerged
in water and then re-emerges new and fertile.
It’s like taking the chessboard of heroes
and villains, wiping it clean and flipping
it over to start a new game.
Ragnarok is also the name of a Thor Asgard
Story from the comics.
Marvel changes a lot of minor details but
the book gives us an idea of who the big villain
is going to be and what the big arc is.
Even though Loki is always an antagonist in
Thor stories, I’ve never seen him as the
villain.
During Avengers the Chitauri were the villains.
During Dark World it was the Dark Elves.
Tom Hiddleston has been up to all kinds of
mischief while he’s been pretending to be
Odin, but he is still under contract to Thanos.
There’s this awesome Game of Thrones quote
that reads, The Iron Bank will have it’s
due.
Thanos is the Iron Bank of the Marvel Universe.
I’ll come back to him, I don’t think Thanos
will play a big role in Thor 3.
Here’s where I need to explain background
for the Comic Story so careful for spoilers
if you don’t want to know.
I’ll just leave this spoiler tag up till
they’re done.
Comic Book Ragnarok preceded Civil War but
both Thor and Captain America were in this
death and rebirth cycle.
Where the only way to evolve as a character
is to actually die.
It’s a really trippy idea and the Marvel
Universe hasn’t tackled the afterlife as
an actual place yet.
But given Death is a character during the
Infinity War, at some point they’ll have
to address it.
Ragnarok starts off with Loki being jealous
of Thor, like most Thor stories.
Odin gives Thor his hammer and Loki wants
one that’s just as powerful.
So he searches for the mold that was used
to forge the hammer.
They might substitute Surtur’s Twilight
Blade in the the movie
In the process, Thor’s brother Baldur is
killed, things escalate and eventually Loki
releases Fire Lord Surtur, who Odin has kept
imprisoned on Asgard for an eternity.
Thor’s arc is all about learning what it
really means to be king of asgard.
And just like in mythological Ragnarok, Asgard
is destroyed and then rebuilt stronger than
ever.
Thor dies and then comes back.
The Surtur Character has a really interesting
past with Odin.
His big weapons are this massive sword he
calls the Twilight blade and The Eternal Flame.
As a young man Odin and his two brothers fought
Surtur, they won, but Surtur killed his brothers.
Usually he’s either trapped in the center
of the earth or Limbo.
But regardless, usually it’s Loki who frees
him.
So Loki might offer Surtur Asgard in exchange
for more power.
That’s really all Loki wants.
Just to be King of everything.
Okay, Comic Book Spoilers Over.
Back to the movie.
The really awesome thing is the cast of characters
are all people from the Thor movies that we’ve
haven’t seen a lot of yet.
Sif has a huge part, even Beta Ray Bill.
I know a lot of you have asked me if I think
he’s going to be in the movie.
I have no idea.
I think they might cut his character out and
just give Jamie Alexander’s Sif character
a bigger part.
Because it’s such a big cosmic thing, there’s
no Natalie Portman.
They’ll explain why that is during Avengers
2.
It’s a pretty simple explanation but just
notice how she’s no where to be found in
this Avengers party scene.
That tells you a lot.
You can see where some of the movie details
might change from the comic.
Loki is already King of Asgard, so he’ll
need another reason to release Surtur.
Who I do think will be the main villain of
the film.
But his release will probably result in the
burning of the world tree or the nine realms.
We actually saw all 9 realms during Dark World
when reality started to collapse.
This one here is where Surtur and the Fire
Giants are from.
You go from the Frost Giants in the first
film to the Dark Elves to the Fire Giants.
There’s a lot of big evil characters on
Team Loki but I think the movie will simplify
things and cut a lot of them out.
The Surtur character is like a thousand feet
tall, so I’m interested to see how the movie
changes that.
If you saw Wrath of The Titans with Sam Worthington.
Remember he had to kill the Titan Cronos and
when you finally see him on screen he’s
so big it’s kind of funny.
Yeah, I don’t think Marvel is going to do
that.
For all intents and purposes I’m going to
think of this as a Tom Hiddleston Movie that
Thor is a big part of.
Technically the movie is called Thor, so he’s
the protagonist.
But this movie is the closest we’ll get
to a Loki movie.
Just think of how crazy the tumblr gifs will
be.
I do think that Thor will emerge mostly intact
in time for Avengers Infinity War Part 1.
That’s where I think Thanos will call on
Loki to collect his debt.
He gave him the scepter in the first avengers
movie.
Now it’s been confirmed that the mind gem
was inside it.
If Loki is in the end credits of Age of Ultron.
He might steal the scepter back.
Infinity War is when I think Thanos will come
to collect both the mind gem and the gauntlet.
Which just happens to be in Odin’s Vault.
Loki will be in the Infinity War movies.
They’re too big to not include him.
I’m actually hoping he teams up with the
Avengers in the second part.
The first film I think will be Thanos collecting
all the gems and assembling the gauntlet.
And the second part will be the Avengers and
the guardians getting the gauntlet off his
hand.
There’s a whole lot more infinity war we
could talk about but for now I’m mostly
going to focus on the movies that are coming
next like Age of Ultron, Ant Man and Captain
America 3.
Just let me know which Marvel movies you guys
want to talk about most and I’ll be sure
to focus on those.
We’ll continue to get new trailers for Avengers
2 before the end of the year.
Usually new trailers come every couple of
months.
In the meantime, click here to rewatch the
first age of ultron trailer.
And click here to learn more about all the
phase 3 movies.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you guys tomorrow!